>> FOX: All right. Hey, everyone. Welcome
to the session. This is one of our--oh, I'll
just press the button. I will press the button.
Tada, all right, so this is Anatomy of a Great
Extension and this one of the--this is the
first actual talk in the Wave Track at I/O.
And this talk is actually geared towards people
that have actually already probably used the
APIs and have made a gadget or a robot, and
they're thinking about how to actually make
their extensions better and more usable. So
hopefully, you know, that applies to you guys.
So to start off with, I want to remind everyone
that we are using Wave as a back channel for
the conference. And since you guys are probably
a fan to Wave, this is, you know, a great
thing for you. So if
you do have your laptop out and you do have
wireless access, you can go to "bit.ly/wavey-ext"
and that'll take you to the live wave for
this session. So, that live wave has a place
where you can ask questions. It has a place
where my colleagues going to be taking notes
during the session and then also, you know--obviously,
it's a wave. You can have free forum discussion
on it. So feel free to join there and we'll
add our resources to that wave after the talk
too, so you can review the slides. All right,
so first, talking a bit about me, so my name
is Pamela Fox and I work on Developer Relations
for the Wave APIs, which basically means that
I'm helping developers, like you guys, write
very cool extensions. Now, I want to know
a little bit about you guys just so you have
a feel for what the audience is. So how many
of you guys have developed with the Wave APIs
before? All right, how many of you guys have
used a wave extension before inside your Web?
Okay, good. All right, so it seems about half
of you guys have actually used the APIs, and
most of you or all of you have used the wave
extensions. So, you know, some of the things
for people who haven't done the APIs, you
know, make it a little bit over your heads.
But I think that you'll still get some insights
from this. All right, so first, let's just
review what Google Wave is, right? It's basically
this communication tool that combines a lot
of nice features into one, right? So we have
stuff like, you know, multiple people on a
wave. You can reply anywhere. You can reply
in line. You can have nested replies. You
can have live editing and real time transition
of what's happening and you can have this
rich media inside your wave whether it's attachments
or gadgets or stuff like that. So really,
this product could be used for all kinds of
things, right? You know, it could be Email
2.0. It could be Wiki or whatever. But what
it turns out being best for is--right now,
at least--is getting stuff done with groups
of people, all right? Basically, everyone
who's really enjoying using Wave now is using
it to do something project-oriented with some
people. Now, Google Wave Extensions, a racy
ways of extending this very generic communication
tool into something customized for a particular
use-case, right? So for example, out-of-the-box,
Google Wave may be very good for task tracking,
but when you add in a task tracking robot
that auto-tags, auto-assigns, create, save,
searches then it becomes--like Google Wave
becomes a killer app for task tracking, right?
So the whole point of Wave extension is helping
these users get stuff done faster and better
by customizing this generic tool even further
for them, right? So as--well, as a developer
making an extension, you should be thinking
about, you know, what does your extension
is helping people do, and making sure that
it's highly usable, right? So in this talk,
we're basically talking about, you know, how
do you make these extensions that users are
going to love and that are really going to
take advantage of the power of Wave for working
with groups of people? All right, and much
of this advice is actually based on advice
that I've given developers. So when you create
an extension, as a wave developer, and you
want to share in the gallery, you actually
submit it using this in wave submission process.
So you create a wave with us in the review
team where you answer a bunch of questions
and, you know, you link to a sample wave,
and then we--basically, we go back and forth.
And, you know, we say like, "Well, you know,
the getting started is a little bit hard,"
or "The thumbnail just doesn't work for me,"
right? So
we go back and forth, iterate. And then when
we're all satisfied, we approve the extension
for the gallery. So every extension that you've
seen in the gallery is gone through this process.
So I've done about 80 of those extensions.
You can see my save, search within there.
And in doing those 80 extensions, I've developed
quite a few opinions and ideas about what
it is that actually makes a good extension.
And I would eventually guess that I've probably
tried more extensions than anyone in the world.
And you should see my toolbar. My editing
toolbar takes the entire page up. So I've
tried a lot of extensions. So basically today,
it's all about sharing what I've learned with
you guys. And, you know, I'm hoping to hear
what you guys think as well. All right, so
I've broken this up into different steps and
kind of go in sequentially through the process
of using an extension. So the first thing
that a user does when they're using an extension
is that they see the installer. So the installer
is how you actually insert an extension into
your Wave experience. So here's a wave within
an installer. Installer is a very basic widget,
okay? It has just a couple parts of it, but
all of those parts are actually very important.
The first part is the name. Okay. So name
should be descriptive and it should also,
ideally, unique and maybe also be a bit Wave-y,
all right? So this, here, this is an installer
for a task tracking robot that I highly recommend,
and it's called Tasky. So it's good because
task indicates its task tracking, right? Tasky
makes it more unique because it actually,
you know, has a Y in the end. The ending Y
is something comes more unique, and it also
makes it Wave-y because if, you know--if you
haven't notice, we tend to end a lot of our
robots with Y. And it's a little bit of a
tradition that we intend to keep doing forever
and ever and ever. So it's a great name for
this robot: descriptive, unique, catchy. Then
we have the description. The description says,
"Use the new wave menu to create task or the
toolbar to create task from selected test."
So this description's really great because
it says how we're actually going to be using
the extension. We're going to be clicking
new wave or we're going to be selecting test.
And it says what happens when we do that.
It actually creates new task. So I know what
this thing's going to do for me and how I'm
going to use it, so a great description. And
then we have the thumbnail or what I call
like the iconography. And the thumbnail here
is a very basic check mark with the simple
color scheme. And this thumbnail is important
for a couple of reasons. One is that it's
going to show up when they look at the extensions
gallery. So when they're clickily looking
through, they're going to be looking at all
those images. And you know, people love to
look at images. So the more descriptive and
catchy you can make your images, the better
because they're going to be drawn to that--to
your extension and be clicking on that instead
of the other ones. The other thing that it's
important is because this thumbnail is actually
used in multiple places when a user is using
the extension. So you want to have it be recognizable
and be the same everywhere. So for example,
this one, here, I've created the new wave--new
task wave basically. And I can see the thumbnail
is the robot avatar, right? So when I'm looking
at the waves that I've created with Tasky,
I immediately know that they're Tasky-created
because I see this thumbnail. So
it's a nice visual recognition for me. Now,
when I want to select text and click a toolbar
icon, the toolbar icon is once again that
checkmark, right? So this is good because
now when I've seen the image in the installer
then it's the same image I see on the toolbar,
it's the same image I see on the robot avatar.
So you want to keep your images and your iconography
the same throughout, and you want to make
sure that iconography is descriptive and recognizable.
All right, so now once they've installed your
extension, they're actually going to see it,
right? They're going to put it inside a wave
and see what it looks like. And you have to
decide, what is your extension actually going
to like? What's the look and feel going to
be, right? What's the interface? How's it
going to be styled? So the way I see it, you
basically have two options or two situations.
The first situation is if you are creating
an extension that integrates with an existing
website that you have, right? And maybe that
existing website already has users. People
already know it. If you're doing that then
you should actually paste "Look & Feel" on
your website, right? Because users will see
your extension, see the website and they'll
make the visual link and think, "Ah, this
is just bringing that website into wave. I
understand that this is the same website."
This example here, this is 6rounds. They're
actually at I/O in the Sandbox pod if you
want to go visit them. And they're an existing
website for interactive video chatting. You
know, they were around before Wave. And their
look and feel is this orange, gray, black,
bubbly, rounded corner thing, right? When
they went to make a wave extension, they brought
that look and feel into the wave extension
as well. So when you look at it, it looks
very distinctively like you're using the app
of another company. And if you decided to
become like a full on 6rounds user and using
it outside of wave, it would feel like a consistent
experience. So as a company, that's probably
fairly obvious for you to reuse your existing
user interface. So then the question comes
up, if you're not making an extension that's
based on some existing website company then
what it should look like? So some people use
like jQuery UI. I mean, everybody uses jQuery
UI. Some people use GWT and some people don't
do any styling at all. But
what I would recommend is that you try to
make your extension look like the Wave interface,
right? Because imagine that a user has like
five different gadgets in a Wave, imagine
each of those gadgets uses their own like
arbitrary look and feel, maybe they each use
five different jQuery UI themes, right? It's
just when you're looking at your wave, it's
going to look kind of cluttered. It's going
to feel a little awkward--maybe a little bit
ugly, right? So if instead each of those gadgets
all mirrored the Wave user-interface then
you look at your wave and it's just--it feels
like this cohesive experience and you feel
like those extensions were actually built
to live inside Wave and it's a happy habitat.
Now the thing is that it wasn't easy to mimic
the Wave UI in the past because the Wave UI,
it's all created from GWT widget that's Java
to JavaScript. And so if you wanted to pull
them in, you'd have to do some crazy copy
and paste, which I did do, but it's not easy.
So what we've done--and we launch this today--is
made a Wave UI library. This is inside the
gadgets API. You can check now the reference.
It's live. And it's simple right now. It's
got a couple of methods in it. And they basically
take elements and convert them into Wave-y
looking elements. So we have "wave.ui.makeButton".
It takes a link element, turns it into a button
even with little mousedown-effects. "wave.ui.makeDialog"
it takes a div and turns it into, you know,
basically what you'd use instead of an alert.
Please don't use alerts as a general rule.
I mean I do it too, but let's just all try
not to use alerts when possible, okay? And
then we have "wave.ui.makeFrame", which is
a nice way to give a border to your gadget.
I always recommend bordering your gadgets
so people know where a gadget ends and text
begins so, that's a nice way to border your
gadget. And then "wave.ui.loadCSS", that's
actually called by each of those, but you
can also call it separately. And that just
imports the style sheet that defines very
basic CSS rules like the body, font family,
font size--so it just takes on the--you know,
the general look of the client. So we just
want this--there may be a few issues with
it. Please, you know, try it out. Give your
feedback. Let us know what other elements
you think you need like, you know, dropdown,
et cetera. Because I think it's really--it's
going to make extensions just look a lot better
if they're all kind of supporting this cohesive
look and feel. All right, so now you've looked
at the extension and you're like, "Oh, its
pretty. It looks like Wave. It looks like
company," or whatever, right? Now you actually
want to start using it. Now, there's a lot
of things that you can say about user experience
and there's actually a talk later at I/O that
you should go to. That's entirely about user
experience. You know, it's always useful to
learn more about that. What I often find myself
telling developers is just to improve the
user experience of the "getting started" experience.
The first few minutes of using a gadget, those
are really important, okay? Because, you know,
they try--they insert your gadget, they see
it. If they can't get it working in two minutes,
they're probably never going to use it again,
right? And as developers, I think we often
forget about this few minutes because we know
how to use a gadget, we're used to it, and
we get then, you know, we get beyond this
"getting started" and we get to the next stage
and we're like, "Ah, it's so cool once you're
in advance mode." But if they never get to
advance mode then you've lost them, right?
So you should really focus on what that "getting
started" experience is like if you want to
keep them users. So a couple of examples here,
this one is your brainstormer. It's a great
brainstorming gadget created by a couple of
students in Singapore for a class assignment
on Wave. And as soon as you insert this gadget,
it pops up a dialogue that prompts you to
fill up the main topic, right? So when you're
looking at this, the only thing that you can
do here is fill-out that main topic, which
I think is cool. Because as a user, I don't
have to think, right? I can just do the first
thing that needs to be done which is fill-out
that topic. So then when I do that, it shows
me the main topic, food. I always think about
food. And then I'm looking at this blank spaces
canvass and thinking, "Okay, well. What do
I do next?" Well, what it does is that this
gadget actually pops up this little call out,
up in upper left there that says, "Click here
to learn how to use this gadget," and points
back to a how-to-use button. And it keeps
it up for about 15 seconds and fades it out.
So this is really cool because if I've never
used this gadget before and I'm staring at
this node in the middle and I'm not sure what
to do next, I immediately see this little
call out in the corner and think, "Yeah, I'm
going to click there. That's a good idea."
So then when you click there, you got a very
simple to understand help screen, which has
a legend and has some keyboard and mouse shortcuts,
all right? And so I can look at this help
screen then do some stuff. If forget some
things, I can always click back on that how
to use button, right? So I mean, the lessons
you learn from this one is making the first
step really easy whether it's setting the
location or adding a person or whatever it
is. And then always making it easy to find
the help screen, help button, and maybe pointing
it--making it a little more clear to people
that are using it for the first time. Now,
another inter-experience that I really like
is this is from CS Odessa MindWave. And this
is another set of developers that are at the
Sandbox and actually sitting in the audience
as well. And they--basically, they've created
this mind mapping gadget. And it actually--it
exports to their desktops afterward, which
I think is really cool. And when I first try
to use their gadget, I couldn't really figure
out. I haven't done much mind mapping. I've
never used their--I've never used their thing
before. And I was presented with this blank
canvass and I just didn't know what to do.
I couldn't figure out the navigation. And
I explained this to them. And I said, like,
"Listen, I just really need a better "getting
started" experience. So they came back with
this, which is when you first insert the gadget
it actually creates a tutorial mind map, right?
So this is just--this is actually the help
in the form of a mind map. So what you do
is you actually browse around this mind map
to learn how to do stuff and you can go and
add some nodes to it, collapse nodes, expand
nodes, et cetera. So I'm both reading the
help and using this interface at the same
time. So I think it's a really cool interface
for learning how to use this, you know, this
mind mapping thing. So this, I think--I mean,
you're not going to be able to do this with
all the things you're doing but it's, you
know, a really nice way of approaching the
help screen "getting started" experience.
So yeah, you can visit them in the Sandbox
later if you want to see more and actually
play around with this tutorial screen yourself.
All right, so now we have to get "to using"
the extension. So here's is we're talking
about Wave-y-ness, which is the characteristics
of your extension that really make it fit
inside the Wave environment and it's really
different from being inside of any other environment,
right? Stuff like ease of use, and look and
feel, that's kind of stuff you'd be thinking
about, you know, in any gadget container,
robot container, or whatever. But Wave-y-ness
is something only for Wave. So let's talk
about that. So first, I'll talk about gadgets
because they have their own unique characteristics.
And first, let me clarify, you know, what
it is that gadgets are and why is it that
we use them. So this example wave here is
completely text-based, right, just using the
textual editing functionality of Wave that
comes out of the box, all right? And it's--if
you can't sell, it's a zombie-killing planning
wave, which is a very common use-case for
Wave as it turns out. So what we have here
is we have a list of addresses which is where
we're going to kill the zombies. We have the
weather, so, you know, sometimes it's shady,
you know, shady weather when you're killing
zombies, and then we have a list of volunteers
for the mission, all right? So, you know,
this is cool. You're looking at those Wave,
you're thinking, "Yeah, all right, I think
I know what it is we're doing. I think I'm
ready to kill some zombies." But what if you're
looking at this wave? This is a wave that's
used gadgets in order to visualize some of
the information that we saw on the other one.
So instead of that list of addresses, we have
a map with polylines and polygons and markers
on it, right? And instead of the weather that
was listing, we have a visual image of that
weather. Instead of that bulleted list of
people, we have a yes-no-maybe gadget. So
now when I look at this wave, I really start
to understand it better and I don't even have
to parse that much information. So basically
the point of gadgets is to extend textual
communication, individual communication where
it makes more sense, right, where it's just
easier for the user to visualize that kind
of information, you know, with the gadget
instead of as text. So because gadgets are
basically, you know, an extension of textual
communication, gadgets should share all the
same properties as textual communication.
And sharing those properties is what makes
gadgets Wave-y. So I'll explain more on this
to, you know, making more sense. So for example,
one property of textual communication wave
is the fact that you have multiple users editing
at once at the same time. So when you see
this in text, what you see is multiple users'
indicators, right? So we call them the user
carats, the colored little indicators with
their names. So here, we're writing this story
and I see that Vadim is at the top, Austin's
at the bottom and this is in the middle. So
it's really helpful when multiple people are
editing at once to know where they are because
that way, you know, you only work on the parts
that you need to. If Austin's working on the
conclusion, and I'm not going to work on the
conclusion because I hate conclusion, I'm
happy to work in the middle, right? And it
means that, you know, we work on different
parts and we can paralyze the work more because
we can see where each other's are and so we
can get to the endpoint faster. So being able
to visualize where other people are makes
you more productive, right, makes you get
that stuff done faster. In gadgets, it's the
same thing. If you have multiple people working
on a gadget at the same time, you want to
know where those people are and what it is
that they're modifying in that gadget so that
you know that you're not replicating work
and that you're going to get this done faster.
So this example, Sudoku, you know, when they
first got this re-launched. And basically,
the goal is to try and solve the Sudoku board,
right, so figure out the numbers that go in
each spot. So what it does is that it visualizes
the colors of the cells as in relates them
as a legend here to actual people that have--that
are in those cells right now. So when I'm
looking at this, I know that Dan is in that
purple cell so there's no reason for me to
be in that purple cell because he'll probably
figure it out first, right? So by knowing
where the people are, we can actually solve
this Sudoku board faster. So generally, you
should try to visualize where it is that everybody
is inside your gadget. I mean, the visual
space for everybody's gadgets is different
so it's not going to always be like this straightforward
grid. But if there are multiple people at
once, try and show people where the other
people are. And if you are using something
like colors, include the legend, otherwise,
you can always use--a lot of people use thumbnails.
People do tend to recognize photos quite easily
except when people use ridiculous avatars.
All right, so similar to that, when you have
multiple people doing stuff in a wave, Wave
actually points out or calls out the information
about your state in a particular way. It renders
your information differently. And I call this
"Viewer-Specific Information". So, one example
is that when you're typing, Vadim and Austin,
they have these colored indicators. I just
have a blinking cursor, right. So when you
look at a wave and you're wondering, oh, where
am I editing right now? You look for the blinking
cursor, right. You don't look for your colored
indicator. So this way, it's really easy for
me to actually figure out where it is I am
in the wave because it has a unique rendering
versus visualizing where the other people
are. So you want to use this in a gadget as
well is to call out the information that's
most important to the viewer. All right. So
this example here, is a very simple gadget
called Likey which leads you like or dislike
things, right. So I click like and it's, you
know, says its total account and then it also
says you like this on the bottom. So immediately
when I look at this gadget, I don't have to
sit there and try to figure out, you know,
did I like it, did I dislike it? I see, oh,
I like this. So this is the same example,
if you're doing something like a game, you
would call out the viewer's score in a different,
you know, visual then the rest of people's
scores because you care more about your score
than everybody else is. So there's different
ways that you can kind of separate or distinguish
the viewer's information versus the other
people, but you should try to do it because
people are always the most concerned about
their particular contribution to something,
so emphasizing that is good. And you can do
this in a Gadgets API pretty easily because
you can get the current idea of the viewer
and you should always be storing participant
IDs in your state when you're relating it
to pieces of information because you know
you can just compare. All right, there's a
current viewer ID and this bit of information
to the gadget was contributed to our business
participant, so I'm going to give this special
rendering. All right. Now another aspect of
text editing in wave is that there are two
different modes of editing a wave or a blip,
one is edit and one is view. And these have
basically, you know, different ways of showing
the interface. So edit mode that's when I'm
actually editing the text in a blip. And here,
I've got a blinking cursor, I have a done
button, and I have a full on editing toolbar
at the top to let me do stuff like bullets
and certain gadgets, et cetera. Now, if I
look at the map gadget in edit mode, it's
similar. It has a toolbar at the bottom for
adding markers and lines, and polygons. When
I click on an info window, it has the textboxes
so I can actually enter in information and
change it inside that info window. So it's
fairly clear to me when I'm looking at the
map gadget in edit mode that I am editing
this information. All right. I'm contributing
to the state of the gadget. When you go into
view mode, when you're textural editing, your
cursor changes, you lose your blinking cursor
and that toolbar at the top goes to just doing
these private read-only actions. So it's pretty
clear that you are in read mode. And just
on a note because I did mention cursor, always
pay attention to what your cursor is doing
in a gadget. I think cursor changes are really
important to users to indicating when stuff
is clickable, when stuff is mouse, you know,
mouse roverable, stuff like that. So, cursor
changes are pretty important. Don't treat
your cursor lightly. So here's view mode for
text editing, and if I go into view mode on
the map gadget, you can see I lose my editing
toolbar at the bottom, I only have the zoom
toolbar left. And when I click on an info
window or simply seeing text nodes and not
input nodes, right. So it's pretty clear that
I can't actually edit any of this information
anymore. Now you don't have to obey the edit
mode, view mode difference in your gadgets.
You could technically you have it so they
can be editable in all modes and that's kind
of the design decision you have to make. But
there are many situations where it really
makes sense to have a distinction between
edit mode and view mode, and we'll see one
in a demo coming up. And if you want to do
that, it's really easy in the API, Gadgets
API, you do set mode callback to a particular
function and whenever the mode changes between
edit and view, because it can change multiple
times, you can get the current mode and you
can switch your interface the cause and functions
depending on when the current mode is. All
right. So actually, on that note, I want to
bring up this team here to show off their
gadget would shows off a lot of the wavey
features that we're just talking about for
gadgets.
>> GODERBAUER: Okay. Thank you. My name is
Michael Goderbauer, I'm from the processWave.org
team and today I'm here to introduce you to
our processWave.org Editor. And the processWave.org
Editor basically is a collaborative diagram
tool for Google Wave so that means it allow
multiple persons to edit the same diagram
at the same time. While I present this editor
to you, I'll point out some of the maybe features
Pamela was talking about earlier and show
how we implement it those features into our
gadget. So, to get started, I have created
a wave here. Right now, it's still empty,
so we should get started right away and insert
our editor into this wave using the button
up here in the toolbar. As you can see, we
currently support six different diagram languages
from the area of computer of software modeling
as well as business process modeling. For
example, there are UML class diagrams for
the computer fellows as well as event driven
process change for the business department.
But today, I feel like illustrating this very
process of me presenting the gadget to you
using the business process modeling notation.
So, that's why I pick BPMN up here. The editor
will file up that will just take a few seconds
and if you would have better Internet connection
that would be a lot faster. Okay. There it
is. And, here, you can see our drawing canvas
and there's a shape repository on the far
left side. So, since each process starts with
a unique starting event, it starts our process
here by dragging out a starting event onto
the canvas, so there it is. Next, mutant activity.
So activities in business process modeling
notation are represented by those rectangle
shapes which you can see here. So I just take
one and put it next to the starting event
onto the canvas. The first activity of our
process would be me entering the stage. So
I just type, enter stage. Next, we need to
connect those two shapes to indicate the process
flow so I did that by using this little arrow
down here. Okay. At this point, I now realize
that modeling all by myself is kind of boring
and if you don't really want to do that but,
hey, this is a wave and it has actually never
been easier to invite all your friends to
a crazy modeling session, and that's what
I'm going to do right now here. So I'll add
my friend, Martin, he is in my contact list
right here. Martin is sitting here in the
audience and we'll just have to wait a few
seconds until the wave has loaded on his screen;
hope that doesn't take too long here given
the Internet connectivity here. Is it loading?
Okay, we just have to wait a few more seconds,
hopefully. Well, I can just use a time to
add another activity here to our diagram using
those shape menus as a shortcut. So, what
would be the next thing, that would be me,
load the extension. Are you with me now? He's
with me now. So Martin will now do some contributions
to this diagram and we should see his changes
to a diagram instantly on my screen just like
you would expect in a wave-like environment.
So, we hope, there they are. So he edited
another activity here, and you might also
notice that the shapes created by him caused
a green shadow while my shapes caused a red
shadow. So we actually use those different
colored shadows to indicate which person touched
a shape last. So the green shapes obviously
were last touched by my friend Martin here
while I touched the red shapes. And in case
if I got, which color belongs to whom, you
can always refer to the editor tips down here
which has a complete list of all colors and
all contributors to the diagram. In addition
to that, you can also have buffer shape and
you can learn more about its last edit. So
this shape here for example was last touched
by Martin [INDISTINCT] and he moved the shape
about 20 seconds ago. To give you even more
information about the modeling process, we
also implemented a little change look down
here which basically lists all changes to
the diagram in chronological order. So, this
can, for example, come and [INDISTINCT] even
you haven't open away from quite some time
and you want to do some catch-up on the recent
changes through the wave. You can just open
here that change look and tweet it. As a little
bonus, we also implement a little under redo
functionality into this change look. So, say
that I don't like the contributions Martin
has done to the diagram, I can just click
here and they're all gone. But, since I will
say goodbye to you eventually, I got to redo
that by clicking done here, and they there
are again. So let's get all focused back onto
the diagram. You might notice that there are
something missing in between. There's a step
missing between loading of the extension and
saying goodbye. So we should better fix that.
I now delete this arrow and Martin is going
to insert a split into the diagram. Now, a
split in business process modeling notation
means that two things are happening in parallel.
And, obviously, here are those two things
would be me talking to you while I present
the gadget on that screen here. So, let me
just add another activity down here and then,
okay. Just, when I added the shape down here
at about the same time Martin also edited,
created a shape up here. As you can see those
two concurrent edits coming from two different
lines were merged into this beautiful consistent
diagram just like you will expect in a wavey
environment here. Okay. Now to finish the
diagram, we would have to add some more arrows
and we also would have to label those shapes,
but since my professor of software, of business
process modeling is not present here today,
I just skip that step as I'd like to say a
few more words about the user interface. Then
we created the processWave.org Editor, we
realized that is actually kind of hard to
create a goto UI for an application inside
of Google Wave, because when you picture the
wave, we have that navigation bound in the
far left, then there's a huge inbox leafing
you with only one-third of the space for our
gadget. So, you really have to come up for
some Slim UI to make produce of that space
because when you think about it, there's not
really that much space. Well, you can see
our solution here up on the screen. We have
created that slim user interface which only
has a few interface control elements attached
to the edges leaving you with as much space
as possible for the extra diagram. In addition
to that, we also implemented a view-only mode
Pamela was talking about earlier. So, when
I finished editing this blip by pressing the
done button down there, all the user interface
control elements disappeared leaving you with
as much space as possible for the diagram
and to think it goes without saying, I cannot
edit the diagram any longer when I'm in this
mode. Well, that's pretty much all I have
to say to you here today. I hope you like
our editor and if you do, I'd like to invite
you to turn your browser to our website, processWave.org,
there you'll find an installer for our gadget
and we'd like to invite you to take it for
a test run. We are also curious to know what
you think about our gadget. So, if you have
the time you should stop by at our spot, in
the developer Sandbox and talk to us in person.
So, thank you very much and we are looking
forward to seeing you there.
>> FOX: I think that's really, really cool.
I'm really impressed. So, if you make your
[INDISTINCT] as cool as that then you're doing
great. All right. So that's an example of,
just a really, really nice wavey gadget. It
has a clear use-case you collaboratively modeling
together and it uses all this nice characteristics
of wave. So now let's talk about Robots which
is another, you know, one of our big APIs.
So, you know, the, let's look at, you know,
what it is without Robots, right. So normally
when you're waving, you're waving with normal
humans. All right. So in this example wave
here, I'm waving my friend Austin or ask him
a bunch of questions, and I'm like, okay,
well, what is life, what is the meaning of
life? So Austin responds really slowly. He
takes about 30 minutes to respond and he response
really just poorly, all right. He thinks a
meaning of life is to drink beer whenever
he knows this [INDISTINCT] to. So, the point
of humans is that, you know, they're great
for, you know, conversations, and opinions
and all that but they're, you know, they're
human so they're subject to faults and they're
also slow. So, Robots are basically programmatic
participants that can be smart because it
let me accessing datastores and APIs and information
systems, you know, outside the wave and they
can be fast because they can respond as fast
as a server can respond, right. So the point
of Robots is just to be, these are basically,
you know, automated participants that can
really streamline different aspects of communication
and make it better. So in this example here,
I'm actually asking about the same question
and he responds within the minute and he responds
with, you know, definitions that you pulled
from a dictionary. So, when you're creating
a Robot, your Robot should have all the same
characteristics of a human, just better, right?
So, we'll take a look at some of the characteristics
of, you know, the ideal Robot participants.
So one of the things about wave is the fact
that people can respond you in real-time and
people can typed in real-time. So when you're
on a wave with another person at the same
time, you actually see them typing and people
really love that moment when they first see
somebody else typing in a wave at the same
time, it's their little wave aha moment. So
real-time responses, one of those great features
of wave but just makes it feel more real and
also when it come to stuff like document writing,
it helps you get stuff done faster, right,
because you don't have to wait for the other
people to edit, you see them immediately.
So when you're creating a Robot, you should
try and create Robots that respond as quickly
as possible, right? So, ideally, Robots respond
as soon as they see something happens. So,
this example here, a emoticon Robot; I'm typing
and I've typed, you know, a sentence and then
I type colon and then I type a parenthesis,
and as soon as I typed that parenthesis, the
Robot detects that and turns that into a smiley
face, right? So here, when a Robot is responding
in real-time and I don't have to wait to see
what's going to happen, I see immediately.
So that's kind of, you know, ideal when you're
doing a Robot like that and in a Robot API
you can register for the document change event
which is the most high frequency event which
occur something like every four characters
so you will get notified quite a lot of when
stuff is happening in the wave. But you can,
now, with the new API you can set filters
to say, I care about document change event
but only if that, if the current blip text
actually contains the information that I'm
looking for, right. So here I set a filter
for smiley face because I only care about
the event if there's a smiley face that I
can convert. And so depending on what your
Robot is doing, you should think about whether
it is that you can actually respond as quickly
as document change and if you can optimize
that by setting a filter. So another thing
about wave is that you can be waving with
multiple participants at the same time, right.
I've seen waves with up to 500 people on it,
right? Actually, I had a wave for one of these
I/Os sessions, the Android, you know, the
Android Wave, there are something like 700
participants on that wave and 400 blips, which
is pretty ridiculous. But, all these participants
are on the way together and they're actually
managing to have conversations with each other
and actually falling in etiquette, right?
They have these conversations in different
places. So, they're collaborating together
on having conversation inside the wave. So
you should be able to collaborate with Robots
just as easily you can collaborate with humans,
all right. You shouldn't have to worry about
adding a Robot to your wave because you're
worried about what it's going to do to you.
You should always expect that a Robot is going
to have the same sense of etiquette that a
human would have. So there's never a fear
of collaborating with Robot and with a multiple
Robots. So to explain this, I usually give
an example of a non-collaborative Robot which
is incredibly; it's just a very bad experience
for people. So this is actually the first
Robot that I wrote and it was called Cartoony,
it's actually still alive if you want to use
it. And Cartoony would take every single blip
and turn it into a word, a cute word bubble
that was colored using the Google Chart API.
So I thought this was really cute because
suddenly all my waves were filled with this
cute word bubbles and, you know, they just
look so happy. But everybody else hated it
because as soon as you added Cartoony onto
a wave, Cartoony would go through and basically
take away all your content and replace it
with all this silly images, right? So people
could no longer go back and edit their text
because it was gone, it was just an image.
Other Robots couldn't operate on the text
that was there because the text was gone.
So, basically, destroyed all the content and
replace it with something that was not useful
and wasn't what people wanted. So it's highly
non-collaborative Robot and my colleague ended
up writing a Robot specifically designed to
kill Cartoony. So if your Robot is so bad
that people create Robots to counter that
Robot, that's a good sign that your Robot
is not collaborative. Or even if people ever
say about your Robot, no, no, no, don't add
this Robot onto this wave, that means that
your Robot is potentially be non-collaborative,
right? So, you need to have your Robot operate
in a way that people aren't afraid of adding
it onto a wave. Here's an example of two highly
collaborative Robots. And these Robots were
both developed independently but they have
the word beautifully and synergistically together
in fact, and this example were, you know,
Robots together could really shine. So here
we have syntax in Monty. So when you put Python
code in a blip, Syntax-C sees Python code
and it applies annotations to that text to
make it look colored so that it's basically
syntax highlighted, right? And then Monty
comes along and looks at the actual text inside
that blip, and basically evaluates that Python
text and outputs the result, right? So you
can basically have this syntax highlighted,
evaluated Python code inside your wave. And
these Robots work beautifully because they
actually operate on different parts of the
wave and they basically miss each other, so
they don't touch each other at all. Syntax-C
sets annotations which, if you're not familiar
with the wave model, annotations are separate
from the text. So can set annotations for
style and for storing custom data and that'll
be restored separately from the text. Syntax-C
only operates on the text and completely ignores
the annotations. And so, because they operate
on these two different parts, they actually
work really well together. So the lesson here
is that, you should think about what it is
that you're operating on and whether you could
be using something like annotations better
in order to not actually affect the content
as much. But it's kind of hard just find what
it is that makes a collaborative Robot, so
give a few more examples here of aspects of
collaborative Robots. So one thing is that
Robots like humans, you should be able to
use human language or natural language to
speak with them, right? When you're speaking
with your colleagues, you don't use, well,
you might use command lines because we're
developers. But, generally, you use natural
language to speak with your colleagues, right?
When you're speaking with a Robot or interacting
with a Robot, you should be able to use the
same thing. You should be able to use natural
language. But for some reason developers,
I mean, I know why, like developers really
like to have Robots that respond to command
line and stuff because number one, we're used
to it. We think the whole world is, you know,
just this big vi shell. And number two, it's
a lot easier to parse, right? You simply look
for that command and you execute it, all right.
So this Robot here, it looked for a slash
map and then an address, it would take that
line and it would convert it into a map, so
it worked but it's back for two reasons. One
reason is that it's not collaborative, right?
Talking about the collaborated nature. If
you have two Robots that operate on addresses
and one Robot says that the syntax is slash
map, and the other Robot says that the syntax
is pound map, then the user can't use both
these Robots as ones because they expect different
syntaxes or the user has to repeat their addresses
with a two different command lines, right?
So it's not collaborative if a user has to
learn a different syntax for interacting with
your robot because it means that that syntax
is probably incompatible with all the other
robots out there. And it's also just not user-friendly
because you don't want to have to memorize
the syntaxes for all these different robots.
So the better thing to do is to actually be
able to respond to natural language. So, this
example here, this robot, Geobot, when you
create a wave that has placed names in it.
It actually analyzes a wave by sending it
to the Yahoo Placemaker API which then responds
back with places that is recognized and the
ranges that they found those places in and
also the latitude, longitude for each place.
And gets--it gets that back and then it annotates
each of the place names with a link to Google
Maps for that location. So this is great because
it's simply operating on place names said
the natural way, right? I didn't use any special
syntax here. And it's also sending an annotation
on these, which means the other robots could
come along and the place name is still there,
other robots could also operate on this place
names. So, it's not easy to necessarily respond
to natural language, right? I mean there's
massive research in natural language processing
and all that. But when you can do it, you
should really should. And there's APIs out
there that would help you, right? There's
Yahoo Placemaker API. There's a couple of
other semantic analysis APIs. There's a group
of developers at the developer Sandbox that
have a robot, an Amazon robot that actually
analyzes your texts to find possible product
names and then links those off to Amazon and
they use this name entity analysis technique.
So, it's not easy but when you can, you should
try to actually respond to this natural language.
All right. So another way that robot should
be collaborative is by being non-destructive
and I kind of hit into this before is that,
you know, your users type stuff in the wave,
you should do what you can to leave that content
there and just add to it. It's always better
to add to content because users can always
take away stuff later, but if you take away
content, then they want to get that stuff
back. They have to go back into restore or
whatever. They have to go and find it somewhere.
So, when possible, try not to remove content,
try to append content and then let the user
decide what to do afterwards. It's similar
to when you're interacting with users like
with other humans, you know, when we're editing
a draft together, if we're trying to figure
out the title of the blog post, we'll often
just put a list of different blog post titles
and kind of decide from that list instead
of actually, you know, replacing one title
one after another with our different ideas,
right? Because if you're not a 100% certain
that a particular content is what you want,
then you want to have all the possibilities
and be able to kind of look at that. So, here's
an example of a robot that went from being
destructive to actually collaborative and
appending. So this is Googley and Googley
is a URL shortening robot. So when Googley
was first submitted to me in the extensions
gallery, what it would do is that it would
look at wave, it would find every single link
in that wave and then it would replace every
single link with a shortened URL, right? So,
that wave would become this one which has
all this Google shortening URLs in it, right?
So, this is bad for a couple of reasons. One
thing is that it's operative on every single
link and not giving me an option which links
I want to operate on. Usually, I'd only want
to operate on a few and it's also gotten rid
of my original link title that I had there,
so it's removed content that's going to be
hard for me to get back. So, when we revised
Googley, the new interface is as follows.
Basically, you have your wave with your links.
You select the link you're interested in,
you click the Googley icon on the toolbar
and then the Googley robot sees what you've
selected and it responds by appending a Google
URL after that, right? So, this is good because
now I can decide which link I want to be operated
on and I can decide whether I want to retain
my original link or combine it with a new
link or do whatever I want with the content,
right? So, it's giving me the option of what
to operate on and it's appending the new information
instead of removing, right? So, always try
to give an option and always try to append
instead of remove. And if you do want to respond
to user selection which I recommend for actually
quite a few robots these days; it's pretty
easy to do it with the extension installers.
You just have--your menu hook for the toolbar
which says there's an icon on the toolbar,
when that icon is clicked, you do annotate
selection which says that this current user
selection will get annotated with a particular
key in value and then your vote gets out on
to wave and your robot will get an event and
it can look through the event and the wave
let's you see where that annotation was applied
and then it can operate on the annotated text.
And there's some examples of that in the article
section if you want more information. But
that user selection paradigm is actually a
pretty useful one. All right. So, that's robots
generally and robots are a little bit harder
to describe what it is that makes them wavey,
but, I mean, generally being collaborative,
trying not to be destructive, trying to be
as helpful as possible, giving users the option,
these are the things to think about. Now,
I just want to touch briefly on a particular
type of extension that could be a gadget,
could be a robot, and could be a combination
of a gadget and a robot because there are
some interesting characteristics of this,
and that type is games, right? There's a lot
of people that are excited about wave as a
gaming platform because hey, it's really easy
to add multiple people on to a game, right?
I always use to make this silly little games
in, you know, college and high school and
I always wanted to make them multiplayer but
I just couldn't be bothered to set up a multiplayer
infrastructure, right? So, wave kind of have
this nice--like multiplayer stuff already
built in and then it also has the surrounding
interface which could let you do other stuff
like combined conversation with games. So
a couple of games here, Shoots and Ladders,
a great card thing. Japanese Chess and Dungeon
and Dragons or, you know, Dice. So one thing
that you want to think about is the fact that--yeah,
let's move this--the fact that in wave, you
can have multiple participants, right? You
don't know how many participants are going
to be on a wave. Okay, it might be 2 and it
might be 300. All right. Most likely on an
average wave, it's probably more like three
or four or somewhere between, you know, two
and six. But I see a lot of people who create
these wave games and they create them as two
player games, right? And two player games
are just--it's not a good experience inside
wave because if you're on the wave with a
two player game and you're the third person
on that wave, you're going to be really sad
because you don't get to play this game, right,
because it's only be targeted towards being
for two people. A better experience is if
the game can actually accommodate more than
two people, right? Multiple people, maybe
infinite, maybe up to some reasonable amount,
right? So, Sudoku is an example that, you
know, supports quite a few people on it. And
another example that I like is Poker which
is a new extension that came out recently,
which is a combination of a robot for the
dealer and a gadget for the visual and it
supports between two and eight participants
which is pretty good size. So if I've got
those two people I can play and I can go up
to eight. That's a nice experience because
I, you know, I can actually have those three
people on it and still get to play. So, I
know that there's a lot of two player games
out there so it's really tempting to put a
two-player game over the wave and, you know,
call it a day. But, like, I encourage you
to think about how you can actually turn those
two-player games into something back and actually
work with more than two players. Because then
you can actually end up turning the game into
something new entirely, right? So, maybe instead
of being two players, maybe up two teams of
players, right, so that you divvy up the different
people on the wave into teams. Maybe, you
know, I don't know, there's a lot of different
things that you could do but it can challenge
you to actually rethink the game and maybe
come up with some new games that we haven't
seen before. So, keep that in mind. Another
thing to keep in mind is kind of the opposite
of that is the fact that on a wave, you can
just have one person. I have lots of waves
that only I'm on, right? I'm taking notes.
I'm checking some tasks by myself, writing
my epic diary entries, whatever it is, right?
So, you can have wave as only single people.
So, ideally, your game could actually be played
by just one person in a wave who's bored and
wants to play, right, because this is a bad
experience if you can. This example here Mafia
which I think it would be a great thing to
do in wave, but when I insert it into a wave,
it says, it needs 48 players. And when I see
this, I think, no, I can't find 48 friends.
That's hard. I don't have that many friends
and I kind of get said because I don't get
to play Mafia, right? A better experience
is something like this Row of Four robot,
when I add a Row of Four on to a wave, it
checks to see if there's anybody else on the
wave and if there is, it lets me play Row
of Four with them, also known as Connect Four.
And if there isn't, it lets me play against
the robot, right? So, if I'm alone, I can
always play against that robot. So that's
the thing to keep in mind with wave. You can
always fake participants because you've got
robots, right? And, you know, it's a little
bit harder because you have to write some
logic into the robots. This Row of Four robot
was 23 lines of Python code and it beats me
every single time. My colleague Roter and
he's really proud and he's going to get a
shirt that says, he beat me in 23 lines Python
code. So, Row of Four, you know, maybe that's--it's
fairly easy to make that logic but for other
games, you may be able to do it as well, so
consider using a robot for your ultimate players.
Another thing is you can do is simply, you
know, inside--this is Colcrop. What they do
is actually let you play against the computer
and their computer is just, you know, JavaScript
simulated player inside the gadget which is,
you know, another example, not maybe quite
a wavey but still an option. And the thing
I like about this one is that it actually
lets you pick between computer level 1, 2,
3, and 4. So, this will be good for Row of
Four where I clearly cannot compete against
the current level of that robot. And I can
pick my lower level because that's the thing,
right? When you're playing games with friends,
you pick through you're playing with depending
on whether you want to win that day or whether
you actually want a challenge. So, ideally,
you can do the same thing with these robot
or computer participants inside games. All
right. So those are kind of the, you know,
the big picture of the stuff that you should
be thinking about when you're making your
extension and you're really polishing it and
trying to make it ready for users. So, we
talked about the installer and having the--and
installer be descriptive and be recognizable.
We talked about the look and feel. Having
it look like your company site or looking
like the actual wave look and feel. The ease
of use getting started, how easy it is in
those first two minutes of using the gadget
and then the wave-y-ness which is all these
different factors, you know, which are unique
to the wave environment. So now, first of
our next steps and for you guys, you know,
basically homework. The first thing you do
is I really encourage you to try other people's
extensions, right? The reason that I have
all these opinions and, you know, experiences
with, you know, good, bad, before, after is
because I've tried so many different extensions
and actually tried to use them in real life,
you know, try to use them with friends that
aren't, you know, wave really wave users,
aren't technical. So try out different extensions
and see what fields could you use, see what
makes sense to use. See what you like, what
you don't like. And, you know, that'll help
and form your decisions because you can think
like, "Well, I'm remembering this gadget.
I didn't really like when that happened."
And so, you can go to the extension's gallery.
If you click on all, I think there's about
55 or 60 in there that you can play through
so that will take you a fair amount of time.
And then once you've actually tried the extensions
and you've built your extension and you're
ready to share it with the world, then you
can submit it to our extension gallery and
go through our extension review process. And--but
hopefully, the fact that you guys are all
here today will mean that the extension review
process will only take like five seconds and
then I can just immediately click through
and we're good to go. But it's really fun
process because you get to actually talk about
the design and, you know, have discussions
about what would be the, you know, the best
interface for it. And also, as a next step,
you should go to the other Wave talks at Wave,
all right, because if you're interested in
making extensions then these talks are going
to help you a lot, right? So, we have--we've
already done the "Fireside chat" in this one
today. About 3:00 pm, we have "Waving across
the web". We're just going to be talking about
a couple of the new APIs that we launched
this morning. Wave this, wave date APIs, and
also talking about the embed API which we've
made some recent improvements too. So let
me check that out. 4:15, that's more about
the protocol then platform, but if you are
interested in wave federation and having your
own wave server, you can go to that. I mean,
the cool thing about wave federation is that
federated servers can actually support gadgets
and hopefully, you know, robots in the future
too. So when you're building your extensions,
you're not just building them for a Google
Wave, you're potentially building them for
all the other wave servers out there. So there's
already a few wave servers that support--loading
other people gadget's in there so that kind
of multiplies the possibilities for the number
of users and the types of users that are going
to be using your extensions, right? Because
our Google Wave maybe consumer-oriented now,
other people's wave servers maybe enterprise-oriented,
so it's a different use case. Thursday, we
have "Making smart and scaleable wave robots".
I highly encourage you to go into that one
because that's really going to--most sophisticated
extensions do involve the robot and that's
going to really give you some tips about making
a good robot and also taking advantage of
some of the new things we launched, including
the ability to have robots not running on
AP engines. So, if you already have an existing
server and infrastructure, you want to use
that to use your robots, you should go to
that talk to learn how. And just go to learn
how to optimize your robot usage and make
them awesome. "Google Wave and the Enterprise"
is going to talk about more of the business
use cases of wave, and also step through an
example of an extension that we would actually
use inside our enterprise for software development,
so for release management, so that should
be a good one. And then 4:45, it says, "Surprise
session" but we announced it today so it's
no longer a surprise, and that's going to
be talking about the attachment APIs. So,
in Google Wave, you can attach things to your
wave like PDFs, images, et cetera. And for
a long time, robots could not access them
but now as of today, they can. So you can
do some pretty cool stuff being able to access
and create attachments because you can imagine
like one person would drag a bunch of CSVs
into their wave and then add on the CSVbot
and the CSVbot would come along and take all
that and then convert it into a map of the
addresses, right? Or another example that
they're going to show is actually being able
to convert a wave into a PowerPoint, right,
and then export it back into wave. So, really
cool stuff that you can do with attachments
so definitely go to that as well. So, including,
you should go to everything, you should learn
everything and you should build everything.
Okay? And in conclusion, I have the cutest
little goodbye, cartoony. Thanks guys. So,
we have two minutes and 10--or seven minutes
and 10 seconds for minutes--questions. I can't
read that far away. All right. So, we'll go
to wave to see if we got any questions on
wave.
>> Can I ask you a question?
>> FOX: Yup.
>> It's open-question to you and to all, everybody
here, the usability question. The gadget that
we build is based nearly entirely on keyboard
shortcuts. And keyboard shortcuts will go
work when the iFrame is host, the gadget is
focused. So now, you should just double-click
the gadget so it will be usable. Otherwise,
you'll be heading enter, it will start new
blips instead of topic [INDISTINCT] or something.
So, what is the best way to indicate it and
how to indicate user that it's not activated
gadget or it shouldn't be [INDISTINCT] representation
or should be some guides--what is the best
decision?
>> FOX: So, you're wondering about how do
you indicate to the users using keyboard shortcuts.
>> Yeah. Or maybe keyboard shortcut is not
a good practice at all.
>> FOX: I mean, I'm not personally a keyboard
shortcut user and I always forget about them,
you know, CTRL C and CTRL V of course but
then beyond that, CTRL E maybe. But, no, I
think keyboard shortcuts--they are a good
thing but I think, you know, what we've started
doing in wave is actually writing the keyboard
shortcuts on the elements so done, here's
SHIFT ENTER. So, you immediately know--when
you look at this that the keyboard shortcut
for that is SHIFT ENTER and we did that in
a couple of other places as well because we
actually analyze--so, one thing you can do
is actually analytics to figure out how many
of them are using your keyboard shortcuts
and which ones are they not using? And that
helps us figure out that we needed to messagize
better. So, I think using keyboard shortcuts
is a good thing. The specifics is using it
inside gadgets. I haven't run into too much,
but I think, messaging it and giving them
a little hint is important.
>> Okay. Okay. Thank you.
>> FOX: So, seven seconds left. We have had
space bar forever but it was one of those
keyboard shortcuts that once again was not
discovered by people, so now, we added this
little button at the bottom that says, next
on red which is basically doing the same thing
as short--as a space bar and if you scroll
over it, it says, go to the next on red blip
space bar. So, this is another one of our
attempts to try and make it clear to people
that actually we've had all these really useful
keyboard shortcuts all along. So, by actually
putting other UI elements in there, so I'm
not sure that we're actually going to have
that button forever, we're probably like evolve
that interface a bit. But it's tricky with
wave because it's an entirely new interface
and you do need different shortcuts for it
so, getting people to use the shortcuts is,
you know, it takes some experimentation, so
we're doing a lot of analytics and stats on
our various attempts here and to try and figure
out if it's helping or what other stuff we
should be doing. Yeah.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> FOX: Right. No, I know. So, I was using
a Chrome extension for unread bullet navigation
which is really cool. It actually will show
you an arrow that points down to say how many
unread blips are there and arrow that points
up that says how many unread blips are there.
That's ultimate. That's what we want to have
in the client, right? And maybe integrate
it into the scroll bar and I don't know what
I would do without that. So, possibly not
due to the paging we did for scaling large
waves. I think that unfortunately we are done.
That's I've been waiting. But feel free to
come up afterwards, all right. Thank you everyone.